in 2014 the qualifying exam for the u.s
physics team had this as question 19.
a helicopter is flying horizontally at
constant speed a perfectly flexible
uniform cable is suspended beneath the
helicopter air friction on the cable is
not negligible so which of the following
diagrams best shows the shape of the
cable as the helicopter flies through
the air to the right
is it a hanging straight down
b hanging diagonally to the left
c this hook shape
d
the inverted hook shape or e
kind of s bend
now apparently there's been a certain
amount of controversy about the correct
answer to this question so today we're
going to go up in this helicopter and
put this question to rest once and for
all
let's go
a portion of this video was sponsored by
simplisafe which allowed us to rent this
helicopter more about them at the end of
the show
i've got several thousand hours of
carrying sling loads fire buckets
concrete buckets doing power line
construction actual power poles you you
name it anything needs to be moved
around the mountains i've done biggest
concern that i have is that the rope is
going to interact with the rotor wash as
it's interacting with the ambient air
around the aircraft and we'll get a
whipping action that falls down the rope
and flips around on the end to a point
that we worry if it will have a tendency
to work its way back up towards the
aircraft obviously we don't want it
getting in the rotors or the tail rotor
all right we're all set
up
[Music]
here i'm deploying a battle rope like
you'd see at the gym this one is about
15 meters long and it weighs 20
kilograms
so if we go really slow will we avoid
that
now the setup looks pretty simple but
few people agree on what the right
answer should be
when i pulled youtube the most common
answer was c
well done on making that beautiful bell
curve by the way
we got in touch with the questions
author professor paul stanley there were
some creative students who actually
constructed their own homemade scenarios
one had a fan
to the side and another fan blowing
downwards so that they could mimic the
motion of the helicopter and suspended a
string and said oh it's this design and
the faculty members looked at it and
said oh obviously
i can prove that the answer is
this answer
they just didn't agree with each other
if we approximate it as a chinese link i
don't think you can just
what do you think i think more you're
more likely to be c i think
it is d o d my guess is b
i'm gonna go away interestingly no one
chose e
have you locked in your prediction
to make sure the rope doesn't come up
into the rotors of the helicopter pilot
craig wanted to keep the rope on our
right side so he could keep an eye on it
looks pretty good
i'm trying to make it look good i mean
i'm really working on it you're working
hard
so we're not going straight forward
we're actually going diagonally forward
and to the left
but you can clearly see the rope is
hanging straight diagonally to the
a pretty good left
man
so the correct answer to the question
is b
[Music]
okay
we're going to try a few more
experiments adding a weight to the end
of the rope and then a parachute but
first i want to discuss why the answer
is b
there are two external forces acting on
the rope gravity pulling it down and air
resistance to the left when flying along
at constant speed these forces must be
perfectly balanced by the tension in the
rope
now when i set out to do this experiment
i wondered if the rope would be affected
by the air pushed down by the
helicopter's rotor
but judging by our results this was not
the case the rotor wash doesn't extend
down below the helicopter all that far
it dissipates pretty quickly so you can
consider the air resistance on the rope
as entirely due to its motion through
still air
imagine dividing the rope up into many
short sections
each section has the same weight and
experiences the same amount of air
resistance because it has the same
cross-sectional area and it's moving at
the same speed
now the tension in any section of the
rope must balance the sum of the air
resistance and weight of all the
sections beneath it so the tension is
zero at the bottom of the rope
and it increases linearly up to a
maximum at the top
you can see the tension is small at the
bottom of the rope that's why it wiggles
around while the top is much steadier
now although the magnitude of tension
changes throughout the rope its
direction doesn't and that's because the
ratio of air resistance to weight is the
same at every point along the rope that
is why a uniform flexible cable hangs in
a straight diagonal line when pulled at
constant speed by a helicopter if the
helicopter flies faster the angle of the
rope changes but it still makes a
diagonal straight line because the ratio
of air resistance to weight is still
constant along the entire length of the
rope
but this got me wondering what would
happen if we added a weight to the end
of the rope here i have a 20 pound
that's a eight or nine kilo kettlebell
and i want to ask you to make a
prediction what shape do you think the
rope will make now will it still be that
diagonal or will it be one of the other
five options one more question for you
if we chucked a weight at the bottom
what shape would it be
probably the
b
or possibly c does that change it then i
think it would be
easy to do on the ground
[Music]
all right we're dropping the rope over
the side
one has a 20 pound
kettlebell off the end of it
how does that feel when it's dangling
no lateral
all right how's your forearms doing i'm
feeling good you know i feel like this
is the easy way obviously
it's gonna feel different when i gotta
pull it up
okay is it down yep
okay let's give it a shot
here the helicopter is flying at nearly
a hundred kilometers per hour
[Music]
and the rope makes a different shape
you can clearly see it looks like an
inverted j
this is option d
in fact this is how the question on the
qualifying exam originated
so i taught for a semester in hong kong
and would go hiking in the new
territories
one of the times i was hiking i saw a
helicopter fly with a cable
beneath it it was carrying something to
one of the remote parts of the hong kong
new territories and i saw the shape of
the cable and thought to myself that
looks a little counter-intuitive and
very neat this might make a good
multiple choice question for the
selection exam for the students the
cable that i saw had a weight hanging on
the end which gave it a certain curved
shape when i shared this with the other
coaches another coach andrew lynn
looked at it and said i think the
question might even be more fun
if there is no weight on the cable
because that is even harder to imagine
to understand why the rope makes this
shape we can use the same analysis as
before but now we need to add a large
weight to the end of the rope
and this means at the bottom the tension
needs to be almost vertical to support
the weight of the kettlebell which has a
lot of weight but not much air
resistance
as you go up the rope the ratio of total
air resistance to weight for everything
beneath increases so the rope turns more
horizontal in order for the tension to
balance out that increasing air
resistance
for the final test i wanted to add
something to the bottom of the rope that
added almost no weight but significant
air resistance
so i picked a veritasium flag of course
so what do you think about hanging this
at the end of the rope well you know
it's all science experiment for me
because these are all the things you
never do with a helicopter in a row what
would be the real risk like tail rotor
or this rotor or both
either any kind of this
tail rotor would be a destruction of the
aircraft
[Music]
[Applause]
here we go
now the rope still seems to be pretty
straight i think it's because the flag
isn't actually adding much drag
still looks pretty straight
interestingly
so we decided to add a small parachute
to the end of the rope alright let's try
it
the concern here was that the parachute
could get flipped up into the rotors
during deployment so we bundled this
shoot up into a backpack
very nicely
does it deploy more than that no but
once we start moving
now with the parachute at the end of the
rope it makes a j shape which is answer
c
with extra air resistance at the end of
the rope but not much weight
the tension has to be virtually
horizontal and then as you go up the
rope the ratio of total air resistance
to weight for everything beneath
decreases so the rope becomes more
vertical to balance out the increasing
weight
so depending on what's on the end of the
rope you could get answers b
c or d
now if you enjoyed this video i bet you
would also like my bullet block
experiment series so check it out
now hanging out the side of a helicopter
was not my safest moment but i do always
feel safe here at home thanks to
simplisafe the sponsor of this portion
of the video simply safe is an easy to
use totally customizable home security
system they allow you to design a setup
to fit your space and they ship it
directly to your doorstep then their
interactive monitoring service ensures
that your home is professionally
monitored 24 7. you know i started
thinking seriously about home security
when there was a police helicopter
circling overhead one day and it was not
dangling any ropes it turned out the
house across the street had been broken
into luckily simplisafe makes it easy to
protect your home they sent me a kit
that took only about an hour to set up i
currently use the simply safe base
station the cameras and sensors to keep
tabs on what's going on around my house
i also installed their new wireless
outdoor security camera which doesn't
require an outlet so you can set it up
literally anywhere this camera has eight
times zoom color night vision and
two-way audio so you can speak to
someone on your property simplisafe's
interactive monitoring service will call
the police if it's alerted to anything
their team of always-on professionals
are easily reachable and always keep
lines of communication open for the most
protective service visit simplysafe.com
veritasium to learn more and get at
least 30 off your simply safe security
system i want to thank simply safe for
sponsoring this portion of the video and
i want to thank you for watching